hallo ich meine lieben filippa dies ja
ich hab dir begrüßen ist endlich mal in
meinem kopf reingekriegt und zwar hab
ich mir gedacht ja das letzte gleichauf
kleines video kam wie sag mal gut bei
euch an also es wird relativ oft
angeklickt was mir halt zeit ist es die
leute interessiert allerdings waren die
bewertungen so also die wahl zwar auch
relativ gut allerdings habe ich ein
kommentar gelesen wie bei du bist so
scheiße du hast spieler gar nicht
verstand eine base ist total müll
du hast du bist level 52 aber hast bei
rathaus wer will was ist mein rathaus
level was rathaus level 9 was soll das
denn ich bin level hunderttausenden
rathaus level 8 alles super ich habe da
sehr viel kritik geübt ich habe direkt
zu anfang gesagt ich bin nicht gut in
diesem spiel ich habe es vor einem jahr
mal gut
der westen nicht gut gespielt aber ich
hab's nicht gut gespielt aber ich hab's
halt oft gespielt also jeden morgen ihn
am mittag mal reingeschaut auch
zwischendurch mal ein paar sachen
gemacht
ich habe jetzt auch aufs spiel sondern
ein ganz klein bisschen beide gespielt
hat ihr mir ein paar sachen geholt ich
habe zum beispiel seit der letzten
aufnahmen im verborgenen testen
hingestellt ich behindert ich find ihn
gar nicht
ich hab keinen richtigen platz für den
gefunden deswegen wohin gestellt ich
glaube das ist die dunkle kaserne die
hab ich nämlich auch geholt und der
verborgene testa da ist der genau das
wird noch gebaut und ich hab halt so ein
bisschen dieses unkraut ringsrum weg
gemacht also diese büsche die sind jetzt
hier wieder neu dazugekommen macht ihm
auch eben weg jetzt soll ich dann einen
bauarbeiter beschäftigt ich bin übrigens
auf dem weg zu den zu den 1000 juwelen
dass ich mit der vierte bruder holen
kann
die sache ist leute ich weiß nicht ob
ich den titel schreiben werde
allerdings habe ich mir so gesagt jo da
alle denken dass meine pace richtig
scheiße ist also meine ganze dings
irgendwann andere youtuber
oder ich wurde von drei anderen clans
youtuber angeschrieben die alle
irgendwie die 160.000 abonnenten der
andere hatte irgendwie 100 irgendwas
1000 der andere hatte auch irgendwas mit
100000 die habe ich angeschrieben ob die
mehr denn weiterhelfen sollen bei diesem
spiel
ich bin mir dabei nicht so sicher weil
ich wollte das eigentlich nicht
regelmäßig hochladen sondern ihr wüsstet
die letzte folge ist einfach schon ich
glaube woche jetzt mittlerweile ja dann
auf jeden fall ein paar tage und ich
habe zumindest pause gemacht haben
geguckt was ihr da so geschrieben haben
gemeldet alle dass es total scheiße ist
was ich aufgebaut habe also ich hab
jetzt in der zwischenzeit die wirklich
mal so ein paar fallen macht ihr so ein
paar diese diese luftpumpen dann habe
ich hier diese suchenden luftminen hin
gepackt und halt so ein paar tellereisen
überall mal hin und sonst habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht mehr viel gemacht
ich habe die beste hauptsächlich so
gelassen ich bin mir allerdings jetzt
nicht sicher wie jeder so sehen wollte
ob er damals du könntest einfach mal von
vorne anfangen einige andere meinten
auch ja du kannst einfach mal unsere
bases thesen vorstellen oder auch habe
eigentlich nicht so lustig habe einfach
nur lust euch irgendwie mal jede woche
sondern holz ausweisen dieses dinge die
da gezogen
ich hab einfach mal lust euch so nicht
wöchentlich sondern einfach mal so ab
und zu mal eine runde zu spielen
jemanden anzugreifen ich habe jetzt zwar
gerade noch ein schild weil ich wollte
ja auch einige male angegriffen da seht
ihr allerdings gleich mal rathaus er
nach außen gestellt haben wir hier zum
beispiel nur zwei prozent dass ich die
da verloren 4 2%
einfach nur weil die auf das rathaus
direkt gegangen sind und dann quasi
trophäen haben wollten wir das mit
relativ egal weil ich jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen elixir spare
also dieses dunkle elixir und ich weiß
nicht also ihr müsstet mir das schreiben
auch jetzt bin ich direkt in den kampf
eingegangen
alle meinten auch doro folgte wie du an
greiss richtig dumm setzt doch da die
hin und warte erstmal ab und blabla bvdw
die ich da weg und so blabla also leute
die sache ist da haben sehr viele leute
herum geredet in den kommentaren als sie
denn viel besser sein das kann ja
nachvollziehen weil ich halt nicht sogar
in diesem jüngsten sowie den mal
angreifen wird nicht so viel ressourcen
dass ich nicht so geil in diesem spiel
bin das weiß ich selber allerdings ich
hab's halt aufgenommen weil ich habe
mich gefragt hat ob ich das überhaupt
mal sehen wollt ihr wollte 10 und danach
zu helfen findet jetzt nicht so eine
ganz gute idee von euch aber das ist
natürlich euch überlassen mit den
bewertungen ich gerade jetzt einfach den
nächsten greifen an audi hat der träger
dieses doppel feature das die eine
tapete mit t online wir ihn einfach mal
angreifen kann machen das jetzt mach ich
hier erst mal auf den einen minenwert
für diese beiden filmchen drauf jetzt
zeige ich was ich meine dass das ist
nämlich so wie ich mal angreifen ich
selbst alle dahin dass sie quasi alle so
als truppe da hingehen und jetzt mach
ich habe scheiße ich habe jetzt gar
keinen fall diesen heilungs menschen
archiv vollidiot erwarte hier fliegt
aber immer noch einer von dahin dahinten
reagieren gehe alle nicht gott der
hatten wir jetzt in einem klaren und hat
der druck so komische krieger die mich
angreifen online egal ist und das ist so
dass wie ich kämpfe oder alt verträgt
sich viele leute drauf ich bin totaler
klum diesem spiel hat muss ich auch
sagen dass es andere sondern so eine art
entschuldigung siedelt er sich so
scheiße bin aber gerade deswegen könnt
ihr mir ja theoretisch weiterhelfen und
sagen was genau ich da machen soll wie
ich mich verbessern kann
aber ich habe jetzt keine lust irgendwie
mit anderen da irgendwie zusammen
aufzunehmen also ist das ist jetzt nicht
so mein ding ich möchte dass mich
einfach so einfach so ein bisschen
spielen das hätte ich locker verlieren
bei meiner ganzen alter meine ganzen
riesen sind gleich einfach schon immer
einfach weil ich keinen
heilung zauberspruch mitgenommen haben
keine personen die da irgendwie mal ein
bisschen cash macht also ein bisschen
den leuten hilft ich hab verloren ich
hab' ich bin jetzt wird er hier auch
noch abgeknallt ist freut mich ich bin
voller marsch ich bin killer ich habe
eine niederlage ich hab nichts bekommen
gut jetzt alle wieder die cool aha du
bist du schaltest du wie du tun könnte
man leute ich war richtig weit ich weiß
ich bin scheint hier drin findet es noch
ein paar leute so wie soll ich die
lämmer trainieren
ich mache mir ganz viel riesen theorien
youtube ich mag die riesen theorien sind
klasse dann machen wir noch diesmal eine
heilung zauberspruch davon brauche ich
auch welche drei die michael allen da
mag ja welche die bombe eintragen
platz für 35 leute habe ich noch ein
paar bogenschützen
ich habe außerdem falsch gedrückt so 15
bogenschützen nämlich hiervon noch ein
paar nehme ich hier noch zehn
bogenschützen auch noch zwei von den
kleinen sondern haben 190 heute wieder
trainiert zweimal quasi wieder ab ist
das ganze fertig ist und in der
zwischenzeit als ich hatte als damals so
dass dieses woraufhin dunkles sie hat
sich halt noch nicht und das rathaus
immer da drin und ich fand das
eigentlich war ganz schön ich hab das
bei inter amerikanischen youtuber mal
gesehen dass er das auto hatte da dachte
ich mir ich mache das aber wenn ihr
jetzt alle meinte ist das total kacke
ist allem auf meine verteidigung soll
total packe ich habe rathaus level
neunaber bogenschützen nicht mal so hoch
upgedatet deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
ich spreche da jetzt mal ab jetzt habe
ich nicht nahezu gar kein gold nahezu
berg ein elixier mehr aber das ist ja
relativ egal ich spiele das ganze nur
das verfahren hat es ja nicht
professionell bei mir die erste folge
des falls ich glaube das sagt schon
alles
ja quasi ist das jetzt noch ein video um
euch zu fragen was ihr sehen wollt das
habe ich im letzten video schon gesagt
allerdings kam da nicht so viele
vorschläge sondern hauptsächlich hält
ich bin ja in diesem spiel das muss
jetzt ehrlich gang
ich sehe schon wieder kommen dass mich
an den kommentaren
hab ich den minister da bitte auch das
wort oder drei tagen drei tagen kann man
das nächste nicht nur das ist halt auch
der grund warum ich damals mit cash auf
gleis aufgehört hatte weil nur einfach
so teilweise ich musste einfach so eine
woche warten bis man rathaus geupdatet
war und so das war nicht so nice und na
ja ich würde sagen auch das wasser mit
dem nächsten video kaiserplatz jetzt tut
mir leid ist immer nur so unter zehn
minuten sind aber ich weiß nicht was er
machen soll weil ich greif quasi einmal
die wien an
und das ist vorbei und das war's also
anno juli sybase also ihr dichter ganz
ganz frei mal eure meinung in die
kommentare schreiben es gibt ja auch so
ich glaube man kann mittlerweile auch
bilder rein post in die google
kommentare also links zu bildern ihr
ladet ein bild mit pu schaum hoch oder
sogar die welt kennt das ist eine seite
kann man spiele job machen und dann
könnte man einfach eine base hofladen
wie ihr das wollt und wenn ihr da dann
cooler kommentare sieht mit kohl belsen
dann gibt einfach mal daumen hoch oder
guck ich mir ein paar an und blendet die
dann eventuell das nächste mal einen
oder bau die dann einfach nach
und dann ist das nächste video sondern
so ein umbau video wie ich meine pace
quasi komplett umbau wie ich dann alle
sachen da vorne hinstellen wo ich mir
dann auch ein schild hole und alles wo
ich dann genug zeit bis alles umzubauen
und alles mögliche machen obwohl wenn
ich gerade am umbau und bin dann kommt
der kann ja eh keiner angreifen ist auf
jeden fall auch egal ich wollte euch
einfach nur sagen freunde
ich finde es schön dass das erste video
so zahlreich von euch geklickt wurde
dass euch das gefallen hat dass ich mir
endlich auf der eins mache ich finde es
auch schön dass größere fläche auf
kleinste leute die sowas machen auf mich
zukam und mir da helfen wollten aber ich
möchte das zusammen mit euch machen wenn
ihre tipps tricks etc
kommentare bitte nicht so was das hilft
mir selber nicht also ihr könnt
natürlich auch wiederum hätten
das haben wir heute gemacht aber was mir
halt gar nicht hilft ist sowas wie oh
ich bin level 80 und habe im rathaus was
nicht sogar das wieder eins und hat mehr
verteidigung und bin viel besser
das bringt nichts könnt ihr gerne
schreiben aber das bringt mir nichts
sondern irgendwelche tipps was ihr mir
empfehlen würde was ich upgraden soll et
cetera
das wäre schon mega ois und dann kommen
noch mehr culture and videos in zukunft
und ich würde sagen das war's wenn es
euch trotzdem gefallen hat würde mich
über eine bewertung freuen egal ob
positiv oder negativ
kommentare wie ich meine welt bauen soll
was ich alle meine kraft machen soll im
nächsten video und dann schaue ich mal
ob ich noch 1
kein werden